do you think that women who voted for
Hillary women who have strongly women
sorry I gotta say it I think those women
are the feminist movement and support of
the left are feeling disenfranchised
given the current climate of sexual
brutality and oppression brought to
light in Hollywood recently uh no I
think they're just going to blame this
oh can we talk about Weinstein so from
what I understand and I could be wrong
this is just off the Dome Weinstein was
saying you could sleep with me to get a
part and let's be honest that's wrong
but all these women were doing it so how
are you a victim if you did it you know
if Weinstein said hey sleep with me to
get this role and nobody did it then he
wouldn't have gotten to do that so if
anything it's more on the women sorry
guys sorry I just I always got to bring
it back to the women it's more on us
because 10 of us sleeping with him or
however many girls slept with him for
the role and there's one of him